good evening everybody Welcome to
statford on aen District Council
planning committee my name is councelor
Lewis Adam I'm your chairman for this
evening just start with um some
housekeeping there's no fire alarm
planned um so if it does go off please
make an orderly exit and the must point
is the car park by the P across the road
um please make sure your phones are
either off or in silence so that they
don't disrupt the flow the meeting
uh just as if by Magic as I say it yeah
is it just
um thank you um this is a meeting in
public not a public meeting um only
those people who are registered to speak
are permitted to do so um I'll give uh
the instructions as and when uh you're
called forward uh we'll go from there uh
the meeting is being recorded and
broadcast on our
website um and now I'll just introduce
the top table from democratic Services
we've got K Keller we've got our legal
officer this evening Amy Shipley our
planning manager is Richard Gardner and
our planning officer is Sarah FY and
Richard you have a statement you
prepared thank you Mr chairman uh just
to confirm my role tonight is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank
you thank thank you very much okay we
can now move on to the agenda proper
then um item one is apologies for
absence we've apologies from councelor
passingham with councelor hatch is
substitute thank you very much um okay
item two disclosures of Interest any
disclosures councelor Eden
first thank you chair uh I'm the
neighboring Ward member for the
application we're hearing tonight in map
of a green or close enough and uh I also
know Mr Phillips who'll be speaking
later um however I'm here with an open
mind so I'd like to carry him thank you
very much counil Harvey thank you
chairman um like everybody else I
suspect I've had a letter from C CBR
limited setting out their point of view
U and I should declare that I've visited
s both sides for tonight's
applications pity isn't it the other one
isn't going ahead
thank you very much Council
pton yeah okay yeah so blanket
dispensation for that uh any other
disclosures of Interest no good in which
case uh item three oh sorry counc it
yeah I'm also a neighboring Ward member
very good thank you okay um item three
minutes uh we've got minutes for the
11th of October
uh take it we've all had opportunity
read them agreed that they a record
agreed Johnny good and the 25th of
October agreed thank you very
much okay I'll note at this point that
item five which is application
23234 washford Farm nnil Street Drive
studly uh was withdrawn so the only
application on the agenda tonight is
item four which is application
23252 ful dog Hill Farm Birmingham robe
um Maple burough green our presenting
officers s when you're ready take it
away thank you
chairman this is an application for the
change of use of
land
I'll start again ad falling
apart only
Char come
now when you're ready thank you this is
an application for the change of use of
land for the stationing of seven mobile
homes for Holiday La Purp and the
erection of an ablutions block the
application site is denoted by the red
line on this plan and is the site is
located within the emerging builtup area
boundary of maple bur green the site's
also located in the green boat and Arden
special landscape
area here we see the proposed site plan
indicating the seven units in the
ablutions block seen
here each unit will benefit from two
parking spaces the site would rely on
the existing vehicular axis of the a435
which is seen here
here we see floor plans and elevations
of the proposed units each unit would
have two
bedrooms on this slide we see floor
plans and elevations of the proposed
ablutions
block this image is taken facing towards
the Northwest the host dwelling is seen
on the left here the car park of the
Harvester can be seen on the right of
the image which is the neighboring
site here we face towards the east the
adjoining premise can be SE in the
background of these buildings
here this final image is taken facing
the Northeast the adjacent petrol
station can be seen on the left of the
image here and the site access is
located here with the host dwelling on
the
right chairman officers find the
principle of development acceptable the
recommendation is therefore to Grant
Subject to the conditions and notes as
detailed on pages 20 and 21 of the
agenda and the updates contained within
the update sheet thank you
thank you very much uh we'll move on
then to our first Speaker who is
councelor in chenton on behalf of maple
bur green Parish
Council good evening
councelor in this instance you have
three
minutes
um okay jolly good um happy to give you
a 30 second warning but if it's prepared
statement yeah I would have thought so
okay um just make sure the microphone's
on otherwise you're
ready good evening um the map of the
green Parish Council opposed to this
proposed development on following
grounds the application is for seven
mobile homes and ablution blocks however
the plans submitted are showing wooden
or timberbuilt Shadows the pl first plan
actually showed one bedroom living a
one-bedroom living area and bathroom
whereas plan two shows two bedrooms
living area and shower room so what
therefore is the reason for toilet block
for the toilet block none of the
drawings are showing that there is any
mobile element attached to this element
to this
application as this from the submitted
plans does not appear to be mobile and
is situated in Green Belt then the
development seems to be against
government the central government who
state in Chapter 13 of the mppf the mppf
and a quote sets out that local
Authority should change Green Belt
boundaries only in exceptional
circumstances and goes on to say that
inappropriate development is harmful to
the green belt and should only be
approved in very special
circumstances it is stated in the core
strategy that any development proposed
in Green Belt must offer significant
benefits to the local area what would
the suggested benefits consist of the
Comm the committee's report last page
items four and five uh refers to the
development as Caravans not sh Timber
Chalet and toilet blocks the repor has
stated that the development will will
not cause any land landscape or
character harm to the area but I would
refer you to the planning application
21420 a part of the refusal of this
which was for the dogin uh next door was
under section cs10 of the core strategy
so could clarification of the changes be
explained the same application was also
refused under CS 59 and 12 so again
could it be explained what has changed
regarding the core strategy between 2021
and
2023 as there appears to be an
inconsistent
approach it also has been noted
regarding the fire report that various
questions have been asked has
confirmation that the conditions can be
adhered to being received from the
submitted plans it would appear that two
vehicles would not be able to pass each
other as shown on Plan Three it's also
been noted that the applicant has
previously not adhered to planning
policy for the area which is green belt
and in the special landscape area part
of the Arden special landscape
area very good thank you very
much we sorry were you done with the
other
statement jolly good sorry I've cut
people off before by mistake um if you
hold on a second members do we have any
questions for councelor shenton from
Paris Council councelor
ke thank you councelor shenton good
evening
um just a point of clarification I think
I heard you say that the you've on
behalf of the parish council feel
there's been an some
inconsistency in the approach to
applying the policies relating to
another application that was neighboring
it um I'm not familiar with that can you
tell me what that application was a
building or a pub or a hotel or what was
it the application
was the application was was for the pub
itself and I think it was to do with
signage um Sarah might be able to help
better on that or Richard um I haven't
got that in front of me I can always
pull it up on here to do with signage um
uh from memory that they wanted to put
on so it's a pub and it's to do with
signage okay thank you very much for
that thank you councel
Perry thank you chair appreciate you've
made a statement on behalf of the parish
council um but you may well be able to
answer this one anyway I know you made
references to the green belt in terms of
the core strategy um but I would wish to
draw your attention and seek your views
um because within the office's report it
reflects to the
it it goes on to talk about paragraph
150 of the um National planning
framework which actually highlights
that within the green belt such changes
of use for Indoor Sport or
Recreation um are acceptable in the
green belt providing the development
preserves the openness which the officer
reports says um can I just ask for your
views on that particular paragraph
because my perception would be obviously
this is a a Leisure recreation facility
um and according to the mppf this would
be acceptable within the green
belt in many ways I it might be better
if you asked me that question when it
came to my statement if you don't mind
um because otherwise I'll be I I'll be
I'd be probably better if I answer that
from from my point of view rather than
the parish
councils yeah thank thank you on that um
any further questions from Parish
Council Representative no in which case
thank you very
much we'll now move on then to um our
agent um Gary
Phillips good evening Mr Phillips um so
you've also got three minutes happy to
give you a 30 second warning um before
the time is up if you just press the
button on the right hand side and
otherwise once you're ready feel free to
take it
away thank you very much Mr
chairman in relation to this scheme
uh the applicant has gone through a
pre-application process which was
supported by officers both from a
planning point of view as well as a
highways uh perspective a decision was
made early on that we would not go for
permanent buildings and that this was
you know a Leisure use and the way that
the application has been submitted and
in relation to the fee paid they are not
permanent residential buildings I should
just clarify so going on to the query
relation to the green belt this is a
Leisure use which obviously would be
supported under policy within the green
Bel
itself there was also been some
commentary in relation to whether this
is a suitable site for a Leisure type
Recreation purpose but I would argue
that it's an infill site where we can
enhance the green space and the
biodiversity where you've seen from
pictures that this isn't particularly an
attractive space at the moment whilst uh
there's also commentary about whether we
should have such a facility next to a
garage uh I should say that my own
office in Studley is immediately
opposite a garage and we have
Residential Properties much closer than
these Caravans will be so I don't see
that as an issue where we've obviously
got uh um effectively a convenience
store adjacent to the site as well as
obviously a restaurant facility and
Pub um some comments have been made from
a technical point of view which have
only been received today in the CBR e
letter which I received at 1:00 we have
actually been discussing potential fire
access for the site with three different
options and uh it's disappointing that
that letter having spoken to Mitchell
and Butler's at length as just sort of
at the 11th Hour appeared but we believe
that uh we can obtain fire access for
this site uh either via uh the garage
itself to the side or via the site with
some demolition of the existing property
which our applicant uh owns as his
home so I'll leave you there with those
comments thank
you thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our agent uh Council
pton thank you chair um I just uh well
first of all can you just clarify
something these are Park Homes
correct uh
yeah they're
parkes they're supposed to be holid LS
so
no they've got wheels on them they can
be moved but they're twin units put
they're temp buildings yeah with yeah so
yeah we're dancing on the head of a pin
that they are technically Caravans but
they they are not touring Caravans for
example these These are static build I
just wanted to clarify what exactly we
were looking at here okay um you talked
about increasing biodiversity I'm
looking at that Google Map it looks like
a lot of greenery there and then I'll
look at if uh you bring up uh Sarah if
you bring up the uh layout of the
plan but that doesn't look like Greenery
there so I'm a bit confused where how
are we getting the biodiversity is is
the Google Map the up to-date one or is
the the previous picture showing sort of
Sandy hard standing there at that so is
that the most is that what it looks like
now yes okay so the the Google image
doesn't show it's changed in there
that's corre okay understand that so
you're suggesting that there's an
increase in biodiversity because you've
got garden areas to each there'll be
some immunity to each of those
effectively so there'll be a parking
area and then iMed immunity Garden so in
theory that is just for green purpose
okay to soften the scheme right what's
your app what is your
client's uh management scheme to ensure
that these are Hol lets that there is
these are maximum two we uh for example
two we occupancy uh are you proposing
for the site's only open 10 months how
how how how does this in Practical terms
not be uh a residential site what what
is what's the management proposals for
this well the management proposals
obviously it would be licensed with an
appointed person that would be um
suitable person I would S Suggest
uh in relation to their background and
that and obviously the site is going to
be controlled by enforcement but as with
any scheme that obviously gets improved
in theory there's going to be a
management policy and how it's
maintained and landscaped okay got it
can I have one final question yeah um
the uh uh will these units remain in the
ownership of the applicant uh yes they
will okay thank you thank you uh
councelor Perry
thank you good evening um I wonder
whether of because they are mobile homes
with bathroom facilities can you explain
the rationale behind the ablution block
having recently stayed in a park home on
holiday in the New Forest we had full
facilities within the mobile home unit
so can you explain the rationale for an
ablution block as
well yeah I mean the the ablution block
is really just to provide additional
accommodation o over and above because
obviously the units themselves are quite
small um so I mean if they were a
residential property there would only be
a one person one um a one bedroom one
person dwelling for instance that would
be the very smallest so clear for
instance if a family was living in the
mobile home for you know a week stay
typically and they were visiting the
local attractions coat and Court
whatever and um you know mom's in the
shower or something like that then
obviously you have an ablution block for
the for the you know the father of the
family or to take the the little kids
you know so that's that's the only
reason really for that
purpose um so hopefully that
clarifies coun Harvey next thank you
chairman Mr Phillips um this is an
application to provide holiday
accommodation the officer's report
highlights paragraph 150 of the
nppf paragraph e material changes in the
use of such land such as changes of use
for outdoor sport or Recreation or for
cemeteries and burial grounds are
acceptable
did uh the word you used was these units
are for you didn't say accommodation per
se you said they were not permanent if I
heard you right you then said they're
for leisure
use Leisure isn't a word that appears in
the relevant paragraph of paragraph or
relevant element of paragraph 150 it
refers to outdoor sport or
Recreation are you contending that
Recreation and Leisure use are the same
thing and is that the point upon which
you rest your
case I think when I actually stated that
I wasn't necessarily making a case one
way or the other but obviously they're
linked to I I believe those two purposes
are linked and you could argue that the
main purpose is accommodation linked to
Leisure and Recreation used for visitors
coming to to the Stratford on Pon aen
District area and that's That's the
basis as I see it um for the argument
for this development to support the
Leisure industry and Recreation industry
within the
district thank you thank you Council
Fleming yeah Ah that's that's the very
picture I was just going to ask about at
the narrowest point where the uh the
boundary does the little 180 degree turn
what's the width of the of the track at
that point
can you tell me I believe it's about 2.5
M how big 2.5 M we need 3.7 for a fire
engine so how's that going to work so in
relation to the access for fire engine
we can we're in discussions presently
with the garage um with the for court uh
where it says
jet um that can provide an access that's
4 M
wide where and because from a highways
point of view the access is
satisfactory it's in relation to the
comments of the fire brigade that have
not raised an objection but they' said
that they would like an access that is
3.7 M wide 3.1 M at the gate position so
our client has um potentially his
ultimate fallback position for the
access and this is why there's been an
addendum uh placed which obviously we've
just seen
um ultimately the wing of that property
could be demolished to provide the clear
access that's required at the side of
the property so we were in discussions
with Mitchell and Butler's the garage
for court obviously Mitchell and Butler
whether this is for leverage for a deal
or whatever they've obviously raised
their letter today at 1:00 saying that
obviously they have
concerns um so there are three potential
ways that that access can be provided to
the site orbe that Dave pilter from
highways at the preup stage and also at
at the planning application stage has
said that there's no objections from a
highways point of view thank you okay
because uh my concern is we're always
told uh that we have to make a decision
on the plans in front of us um and those
plans don't include what the things that
you've just said from that perspective
so it's just something I wanted to bear
in mind when I make my decision later
thank you thank you thank you any
further questions for agent no in which
case thank you very much for your
contribution now move on to our W member
who is once again councelor
shenton welcome
back uh you've got five minutes this
time yeah no worries at all um so as I
was saying you got five minutes again
happy to give you a 30 second warning
and um once you're set up uh feel free
to take it
away
my objections uh to this application is
set out in the committee report there
are 20 objections from residents and
businesses to this application proving
just how unpopular this is amongst
residents the parish council local and
National businesses uh plus myself all
the objectives of raised valid points
are sumarized in the report but three
objectives stand out one from Mr and Mrs
hail who employed the planner one from
Mrs Topham and one from Mitchells and
butlers who employed an international
planning firm and their report is signed
by an associate director a member of the
royal town planning Institute the
elevations indicate and if we could move
to my my slides please the elevations in
indicate Timber constructions and are
possibly incapable of being moved from
one place to another in the legal sense
of mobile homes our own licensing team
have reservations about what is going to
be allowed on this site I'll explain
more on this later as they've not been
properly
consulted therefore cs24 may not apply
due to their possible permanency this
notion of permanency permanency is
reinforced by statements that they have
Gardens in excess of 50 square meters
and that space for vegetable growing is
incorporated a feature that you probably
wouldn't see in on
holiday the description varies amongst
the de the document and the committee
report itself which has been commented
on by the aforementioned planner acting
for m&b to highlight this could we move
to slide two please the elevations in uh
one before that I think uh that sorry
that that other one go back to that yeah
that indicates that they're wooden as in
this slide uh next slide please the
committee report says that it is to site
seven Caravans like this one next slide
please please the application says it's
a change of use of land for seven mobile
homes like these whil hybrid design say
that it's for seven holid Els which
could be any of those pictures as you
can see they're all different and it
begs the question of why terminology is
not consistent and the application is
not clear about what will be cited the
agents however hopefully helpfully
inform us that a pre-application was
submitted at the end of 2022 by the
client with consideration of a gypsy
traveler site as an alternative
scheme so is this really a holiday site
other key matters fire safety uh if we
go back to the very first slide that
shows a layout of the site with the
arrow highlighting where there is a
pinch point it's not clear whether a
fire tender could actually get past this
pinch Point again our licensing team
have share the same reservations but
were not consulted this is just one of a
number number of conditions that the
warshire fire and rescue service have
asked for and supports my view that the
conditions imposed by the fire and
rescue service are such that this site
may not be capable of being compliant
with the mppf paragraph 112d or part C3
of the SDC development requirement SBD
the CBR report also states case law bin
versus monasa County Council and
indicates that the planning committee
report should not be misleading and that
all material matters should be brought
to members
attention the fire and rescue report is
a material matter in this consideration
in this application the committee papers
make barely any mention of the fire
service conditions if you are minded to
approve despite the concerns then these
conditions need to be incorporated to
the approval other key matters
separation regulations suggest a six
meter separation between structures for
fire safety this is standard on holiday
and it's not clear that these units and
the oolution block comply with that
regulation the regulation is rigorously
enforced by all major camping Caravan
and motor home sites again our licensing
team share the same reservations but
were not consulted if we go to the last
photo fast last slide please taken from
the this is a picture taken from the
East looking into the application site
which uh you've already seen one earlier
on as we're not moving my slide the
openness of the countryside will be
impacted as a fence is a low fence and
as you can see there is green areas all
around in any case this should be
resisted except in very special
circumstances quite clearly the site
will be visible and is in appropriate
development so it fails uh the
test moving
on I ask you to refuse permission
because it fails on every test against
the core strategy including uh some of
the highways issues has inconsistent
terminology is silent on material facts
and in addition because if you approve
this you are effectively Ty in the hands
of our licensing team who should have
been consulted prior to the resort
reports being put together I spoke with
Paul Reed at 4:30 this afternoon as I
was concerned about this issue and he's
confirmed that he wasn't consulted I can
highlight some of the regulations have
to ask you to wrap it up now please
councilor sh thank you uh okay um
members do we have any questions for our
Ward member Council
pton
question
issues yeah can you summarize the key
issues that the licensing team have
around this site thank
you I can before you uh do come back on
that I'd just like to make clear that
licensing isn't um material to the
planning process we have to be
absolutely clear about that and so I I
will allow you to answer but please keep
it incredibly brief thank you the point
about the licensing team is that if
should you approve this application then
the licensing team's hands are tied to a
certain
degree they are concerned that the the
about the pinch points they're concerned
about the type of
um uh dwelling that's going to be put on
this site um and they're concerned about
separation points all these matters are
key matters on the site on a tight site
next to what is a petrol
station uh a main road pinch point where
if there was a fire and often these sort
of units use LPG gas so you have LPG gas
you have petrol you have wooden Chalet
or buildings in a tight confined
site
licensing would have trouble with
that y okay any further questions for
our war member Council
Perry chair I did ask um councilor
shenton a particular question on um mppf
paragraph
150 um if you would like to respond to
that question um which
highlights um in the green belt that um
such changes of use for outdoor sport or
Recreation and at the end of the
day there is a perception that holidays
could is a form of recreation I just
wondered whether you could just respond
to that particular query that those sort
of activities for change of view are
acceptable in the green belt I think our
our our view combined view is that the
there is not certainty over what's going
to be cited there in particular the site
is open if we went to my last slide
which we didn't get to but if we went to
the last slide you would see that that
area at the back of the property is is
Hardcore or gravel already but beyond
that
its green belt and you can see clearly
see out and in to the site so any that's
uh that and that's a low fence that runs
along that boundary so that's not a high
fence that's a a very low fence when you
can you so you would clearly see those
from the East and if you look into the
site from the road you could see up the
drive not very well up the drive we'll
say but from the East they're clearly
seen it it doesn't fit in with uh Back
Garden development I think CBRE
described it
as anywhere else this this kind of
development isn't anywhere else down
that part of the road the
a435 is is a is a busy road um but this
this as far as this goes we would query
whether in actual fact it is for holiday
let and whether the green belt is at the
openness is affective
so we would contend that the openness of
the green belt has and will be
affected any further questions from our
war member no in which case thank you
very much for
contribution all right uh we can now
move on then to points of clarification
from our officers Council pton where to
go thank you I have a couple of areas I
want to seek some clarification first of
all I want to seek some clarification in
relation to the consultation by CC
Street Scene so if these were
Residential Properties we would be
looking for tracking to demonstrate
access to and erress from the site for
resued
vehicles um in planning
terms is there is there not any similar
collery for commercial waste
collection in other words is there not a
requirement for any planning application
to demonstrate that there is a scheme to
be to enable able collection of waste
because it's only going to be collected
by a
truck that that just
seems unusual so I would be Keen to get
some understanding of Are We suggesting
that uh there need there need not be
things like tracking and access if it's
a commercial
scheme that's my first point and I've
got a second
one I'd like to defer to Richard on that
point if that's
okay um I would say that with a
commercial scheme you would have um the
large wheelie bin um which would be
wheeled to a suitable point for
collection by whatever commercial
vehicle they'd arranged to um have it
collected by um the difference being you
wouldn't need to get a a bin Lorry onto
the site as you would for a residential
scheme chair if I may um I'd like to dig
into that answer a little bit more
that's not actually answer answering the
question I asked is whether in planning
terms is there a requirement for an
applicant to De to to to
demonstrate suitable access and egress
for refug collection vehicles on quote a
commercial site I mean this is quote a
commercial site because it's not
residential homes but it is in essence
Residential Waste we're not going to be
putting bins on this thing one assumes
it will be wheelie bins but um I I want
to understand the question is is there
requirement to allow for that you you
asked you answered on the Practical
Point somebody will whe the big wheelie
bin out maybe maybe not but from a
planning perspective is there a
requirement to demonstrate a vehicle can
get on and off the site as it would for
residential for a commercial yes but
this isn't a commercial what I could do
is go away and check what our SPD says
in relation to this if that would help
um is that something we can you can do
while we're I could do whilst you're
asking other questions yeah okay if you
would please that would help um chair my
second question relates to the update
sheet
um uh and we look at the off the the
response from the fire safety officer
and there is this updated recommendation
that talks about the application being
granted uh subject to a scheme for
arrangements to be made um to me this
seems
well it's it's access this is a
fundamental part of hearing an
application is access to and from the
site so I'm I'm going to ask the legal
officer are we actually in a position
where we should be considering this
where we can't actually determine access
to and from the site uh and if there is
some doubt about that uh my next move
well potentially is a deferment um but I
would hear other I would I would wait
till debate on that but I I want to
understand this this seems really
fundamental
um yes so um I've spoke to um Richard on
this um they've spoken to the applicant
they believe there is potential for
Solutions um obviously that that's not
being consulted with the fire and rescue
Authority as yet which is why we've put
that forward on its own it wouldn't be
strong enough to refuse um because there
is a potential for a resolution so if we
were to refuse on the basis of this
reasonal loan and it went to
appeal there is a risk of there's
potential costs if it's a sole reason um
on the basis that the applicant may be
able to demonstrate a solution um which
is why we are suggesting that if there
is an opportunity to consider something
we should do that can I get more
clarification on that I'm afraid it's
got to be more than hope value in terms
of this access um we are reliant upon
one or two other land owners and
Commercial organizations to play ball
one has already indicated that they're
not interested in playing ball um the
applicant has also indicated well I
could just knock part on a bungalow down
but this is development in the green
belt and changing the shape of the
building as far as I can see would
require a plan and application to change
the shape of the building to demolish
itation doesn't require plan and
permission okay at least on two points
it strikes me that this is Hope value at
best
there is you know if you were saying to
me you know there was a copper bottom
agreement and there was there was an
application that was refused on access
GRS in bidford that came back uh where
there was a change to access it was
actually laid out and the committee saw
that uh I'm still not convinced that
there is a risk here this the access
cannot be demonstrated and you've got a
fire service asking for
um they they want to be satisfied about
this and I don't see how at this point
we can be satisfied if um okay I'll
leave it at
that I appreciate your comments thank
you uh coun
Perry thank you um i' just like some
guidance on this one um if in the event
that we
um continued with the debate and didn't
go down a deferral route um can you
advise would it be possible to add a
condition um
unrestricted use to 10 months a year
which is quite standard for Holiday
Caravan Park that are
nonresidential and if so was this a
condition that was considered by the
officers
I think sometimes with um sites such as
their still holiday that sites there is
like a seasonal condition or something
like that but um this is something we
discussed on whether there should be a
time restriction but we didn't consider
it was a reasonable condition to
add need to
add thank
you councel
Harvey I'd like to pursue this paragraph
150 of nppf and have some see if I can
get it clarified in my own
mind here we're talking about an
application for a change of
use and one of the permitted grounds
where it could be within the spirit and
letter of the nppf is if the change of
use is to provide outdoor
sport or and I'll import a word outdoor
recreation
now
in his explanation Mr Phillips referred
to recreation in The District in other
words this would be provide this change
of use would be
providing
accommodation which would enable
Recreation to be take to take place
elsewhere it seems to me that paragraph
ties the outdoor sport or Recreation
specifically to the site so so what I'd
like you to tell me is is there a case
law which defines
Recreation and it does Recreation mean
Leisure are they absolutely in planning
terms
synonymous if I could answer this one Mr
chairman it it's not a question that you
need to answer in order to consider it
against paragraph 150e of the
mppf um paragraph 150e um does allow in
the green belt material changes in the
use of land and then the bracketed part
says such as changes of use for outdoor
sport or Recreation or for cemeteries
and burial grounds it gives those as
examples it doesn't give them as
exclusive ones that can go ahead so it
doesn't rule out applications like this
such as changes of use um to a caravan
site as it is in this case um the test
is whether it preserves the openness or
conflicts with the purposes of including
land within the green belt and those are
the things that you need to look at to
decide whether a change of use is
acceptable c
p y very good um I have any further
points of
clarification c h serin yeah uh points
of clarification on Green
Belt um as far as I can remember there
is a percentage of land that you can
hard stand in hardcore on but you can't
do the whole
site am I right on that I think the
percentage you're referring to is in
household the permitted development
rights a householder can only
hardstanding a certain proportion of
their Garden um that doesn't apply here
there's no PD rights because lawfully it
is agricultural land so there's no PD
rights there anyway so any hard standing
that's there today is
unlawful um any hard standing in the
future or garden areas would be picked
up by the condition in your report which
is number three a hard and soft
Landscaping scheme but there's no PD
rights to do what they've
done C Harvey thank you
um what is the relevance of the need for
public benefit
in determining this
application um you'll need to find
public benefits if you conclude that um
this development is inappropriate
development within green belt or it
harms its openness you'll then need to
outweigh that harm with public benefits
but only if you get to that point do you
need the
public C
Keithley yeah thanks very much chair um
on the same Vein on page 18 when we're
talking about paragraph 150 you
explained that allows the change of use
um and gave some examples of the sort of
change of use it could be it's not an
exclusive uh or defined list um but you
then go on to say as the cuz we've heard
from the the ward member that there
there's potentially impact on the Green
Belt here you go on to say as the site
is enclosed on all four sides by
development you consider that this site
if it was developed would preserve the
openness of the of the green belt could
you help me understand the four sides of
development again could you perhaps put
up the slide
because if if in fact there is
development on all four sides then I'm
I'm struggling to understand why it's an
open site I I I looked the first time I
looked I thought I saw that it was open
at the back but perhaps
not yep happy to explain that so the
host dwelling is sorry I just changed my
cursor so you can see
it um the host dwelling is here so
enclosed on that side by development the
petrol station the jet is located here
this is a Chinese restaurant and some
land to the rear of that and this land
at the back is associated I understand
with the garden center which sort of
wraps around the site and then we've got
the Harvester the the dog to the north
that's that's why I described it like
that okay thanks that's quite helpful so
behind the site there is um all that car
parking area what appears to be like an
industrial
shed so the only you have to go beyond
that to get to an open view that's what
I'm saying yes yeah okay that's
interesting thank
you thank you any further points
clarification C Harvey just while you've
got that slide up are there any foot
there's no there's no mention in the
papers of any rights public rights of
way no foot paths but are are there any
foot paths or walkways adjacent to the
site at all that members of the public
could
use I would have to check that for you I
can do that now if you'd like
okay
so the SPD on uh refuges and recycling
is part
P
um there are sections on Residential
Waste and there is a section on
Commercial waste there's nothing that I
can find in answer to your question
that's specific to this type of
development um so if it's a concern to
members you could put a condition on
requiring requiring details of um refuge
and recycling facilities um to be
submitted prior to development taking
place sorry should I come back to
councelor Harvey's question um if you
can see the OS map here the site is
that's the pub if you can see my cursor
so the nearest probably right away is up
here as far as I can
see some distance from the
site thank you uh Council keithly I'm
Keen to move on to De
base we've seen different illustrations
of what these units look
like is it a is it going to slightly be
conditioned that they they must be
mobile units I mean that's that's what
the application says I guess that means
you can lift them up and move
them that yes so if we just look at the
conditions on page
20 um
officers have recommended a condition
that they
will be no more than seven Caravan
station within the red line this means
that as it's a change of use of the land
the carons could be moved within the
site um and um we've we've if you look
in the update sheet there is a
suggestion to amend condition five to
also ensure that the mobile homes meet
the definition of the car of a caravan
set out in the Caravan act thanks very
much
can just everything is it as quickly as
possible before we move on thank you can
I just ask have um War highways been out
on a site visit at
all yes I was speaking to the highways
officer yesterday and he went to the
site yesterday lunchtime to check the
visibility slays and he was satisfied
that they were
acceptable thank you uh I think we've
been fairly exhaustive so I'm happy now
to move on to the
I'm aware council pemon is Keen to
start thank you um I'm going to be
recommending that uh we go for a refusal
in this and I'm going to explain why uh
first of all to pick up the Caravan
mobile home Point um they're technically
Caravans they've got wheels they never
move these things have got Gardens
they're they're they're in essence
permanent for their entire design life
but they are technically Caravans um
this is development in the green belt
and by definition development in the
green belt causes harm um and it
paragraph 137 of the mppf talks about
openness and permanence and with the
picture that uh I accept the point that
there is uh some commercial use at the
back of the site but it is still visible
to the rest of the green belt it doesn't
um just because some of the openness of
the green belt is diminished does not
mean to say that you should increase
that diminishing of the openness um I
have not seen anything whatsoever that
ties uh the identification of every of
any very special circumstance to
demonstrate the harm of further
development in the green belt paragraph
um uh the examples are quite specific I
think the officer is suggesting that the
test should not be um such has changes
for and the the thing about Recreation I
think is a red herring you have to read
in any contracts in any legal document
the sense so outdoor sport or
Recreation those are activities that is
not living there for leisure ablak
Recreation so I don't think that
Recreation I don't think that Leisure
occupancy meets one of the examples nor
do I accept the premise that it could be
anything else residentially so far away
from the or Leisure uh tourist
accommodation is so far away from
outdoor sport or Recreation or
cemeteries and burial grounds if the if
it was in the policy makers Minds to
intend to include Leisure accommodation
it would be an example I think as
decision makers we are legitimately
entitled to say um materials material
change could be acceptable under 150e if
it is things such as outdoor sport or
Recreation or for all four cemeteries
and burial grounds I think that's a
limited list I think even if you ex
expand the list I think it's a huge jump
to say that it is uh Leisure
accommodation and I don't believe that
150 uh e uh is is engaged here um I also
think that the erection of the ablutions
block is not required an ancillary to
this to the development of this or of
this application because the application
um buildings have their own toilets and
showers um and therefore the ablutions
block itself is additional um
development in the green belt which
restricts its openness um I I don't see
that is necessary they've got toilets
they've got showers um overall I think
this is inappropriate development in the
green belt I've seen no special
circumstance I don't believe 150e
applies I think the ablutions block uh
diminishes uh the openness of the green
belt even further um and that leaves
aside the fact that before we even get
to now we've not only have we got lack
of access for fire service we've got no
clarity about access for refuges either
I'm I'm unhappy that we're considering
it with those two things still left out
there I definitely wouldn't be prepared
to accept anything that didn't have both
of those things coming back to this
committee to be C copper bottomed out
rather than leaving officers to it but
before we get that I'm I'm pitching for
a refusal on the grounds I've outlined
um I'll listen to the debate and see if
anybody else goes that way thank you
thank you very much I'll take that as a
formal proposal thank you Council
Perry thank you well I actually have a
dilemma with this whole this whole
application because I feel it is
incomplete I do not feel that we can
make any sensible decision on it because
there is a big question mark over the
access for fire engines and therefore my
proposal would be for to go for a
deferral so that we we we look at this
application that is complete there are
too many unanswered questions here um so
that would be my um proposal going
forward thank you very much councelor
Eden thank you chair uh I have to say
um I feel the same as councelor Parry um
it feels incomplete it feels like we're
loading it with conditions just to get
it over the line and ticked
off a lot of it troubles me the
ambiguity about what what the Caravans
or mobile homes will be um not so sure
about the ablutions block I share
councelor pemberton's concerns about
that sort of not necessarily being
necessary um however um I'm not going to
go quite as Hardline as him um I I think
that we need to see more Clarity and
have a complete application in front of
us to be able to consider it and approve
it or refuse it appropriately so I would
like to Second councilor paris's um
proposal thank you very much Council hen
s next yeah I have concerns wholly with
this
application obviously access for fire um
the mobile homes look more like shell to
me not like the normal mobile homes um
I do know about this roundabout and the
amount of traffic that comes around it
they actually speed there's been quite a
few accidents there and this is only
increasing that because it's very
difficult to get off the for court of
the petrol station never mind moving
further to the roundabout so I have very
firm reservations that this is not quite
the right application at the moment
thank you thank you CC hatch
um I'm I go for referral as well and to
as well as the important issue of fire
access to can they do a climate change
checklist before it comes
back who done C Kei
yeah okay thanks chair
um my reading of this is um is slightly
different I I I actually disagree with
councelor pton on a number of issues I
think that Park home style accommodation
for Holiday lets is is sort of on Vogue
actually my cousins bought something
they go fishing and that's exactly what
they've got they call it a lodge
actually but they let it out and people
have holidays there I think that's
better than a garden shed personally and
better than a caravan um I've read what
what the planning officers said about uh
Leisure occupancy um under the national
planning policy framework 150e I think
it does apply so I disagree with
councelor pton on that um there's going
to be a condition on occupation so it's
not permanent living it's holiday only
we've heard that um the definition of
mobile will apply to to these Caravans
not going to be permanently cited but
there'll be Park home style developments
um is okay in the green belt it's
surrounded on four sides by development
um how exactly you can argue that having
some development on this site which is
an open site at the moment makeing any
difference when you got surrounded by a
garage a pub and a uh huge industrial
looking building and a load of car
parking associated with the garden
center I don't know but I can't see that
I think that's okay um in respect of
what councelor hen sarapin has said
about accidents and speeding I've got to
say highways have been on site they've
got no objection and we have to go with
the experts rather than uh anecdotal
information um so in respect of what I
see presented for the development um I'm
satisfied that the planning officers
have reached um a fair decision however
uh I am concerned about the access for
fire and I think this is an area that we
need unless it can be conditioned that
no development is put in place until the
a suitable width of access is provided
either by De demolishing some of the
host property or seeing a um a formal
deal in place for Access through one of
the neighboring properties I'm very
uncomfortable if it can't be conditioned
I don't think it's satisfactory that we
should allow it to go ahead not knowing
that the development can proceed safely
so um my view is that I think we should
defer it if we can awaiting further
detail on the access for fire but I I'm
I'm not happy to put forward material
planning reasons for this not going
ahead I'm just concerned about the the
fire
access thank you very much uh any
further comments for the
debate um I mean there's we've we've had
the proposal for deferral seconded um
and I I have mixed feelings about this
but I feel that actually deferral is
appropriate in this case to address the
the things that are quite plainly
evident in in in that they're lacking um
namely the the fire and and rescue
aspect I would like also some clarity on
the refu collection because I think that
was a relevant point that councilor pton
did raise um the my feelings on the the
aspect of the development I think if
it's hard to say exactly how how the
openness will be affected because the
surrounding nature of the site is of
different levels of different types of
development it's on the edge of a
settlement I I can appreciate why
there's concern about it green belt has
to be taken very appropriately seriously
but this is a tough site to say there's
definite
harm so I think that's where I'm I am on
that so ultimately I'm I'm happy to go
with deferral myself as well um so that
we can try and at least bottom these
things out and then we will be in a
position to make a firm decision as a
council and local planning Authority so
that's the way I'm going to go um so
there's only that one proposal at the
moment um can I see all those in favor
of deferral
please
Ace all those
opposed one and
extensions I'll take that as one
abstention um in which case committee
resolves to defer application
ful uh for the reasons given
okay as previously mentioned item five
was drawn and therefore we now move on
to item six urgent business no urgent
business in which case I declare the
meeting closed thank you very much
everybody